and that changed the trajectory of his
life where Silicon Valley starts calling
them and you know and evolve flies them
out to San Francisco and wants to invest
in a [__] like that so so snapchats kind
of pushing their chips into the middle
of the table and saying come build [__]
on us we'll treat you better than those
guys will and you kind of leave it you
kind of believe it because it's really
their only way to compete with Facebook
and Instagram so they kind of have to
actually honor this so anyways a quick
idea so in general I think that being
early to these platforms and these app
app ecosystems is a good thing there's
been several snap kit apps that have
been like number one and number two on
the App Store so they've gotten a [__]
ton of distribution from it what's a
snap kit app snap kit is basically the
toolset that snapchat gives you to build
to build stuff so it's like okay snap
kit will say you want to access their
bitmoji cool snap kit lets you just type
one line and you get their bitmoji
character you can do stuff with snap
kits their camera with all their lenses
I'm doing this course with Goggin and we
talk about our inflections inflections
there's a variety of styles of
inflections there's technology
inflections which is like basically like
oh my god the Internet is now in
everyone's house that is an inflection
there's an opportunity there or a belief
inflection is like wow people really
don't trust the media what can we build
help or people are afraid to be in
groups of thousands of people how can we
fix that what we are seeing right now is
a technology inflection or a platform
inflection yes and this is it this is
like when so Pandora the music company
Tim told me that the company was around
for three years and it was doing
horrible and he said they heard about
the Apple Store for some reason Steve
Jobs reached out to them and said you
guys might be a good like place to put
your [__] here
once that happened he was cool and this
I don't know if it will be but this is
potentially one of those yeah these are
asymmetric bets sure maybe most of the
time these platforms either don't work
out or there's nothing cool to build and
you'll waste you know a month of your
time or you might catch a wave early and
you might get to the top so for example
the very first episode of this whole
podcast chain is with Tsui and so he
talks about he was working at Microsoft
and he realized he wants to quit and go
start a company quits he moves back home
with his parents for like two weeks and
the fruit and the first two weeks he's
kind of bored and the day he quit
basically Facebook did their developer
conference and said hey we're making
Facebook platform anyone could build an
app on Facebook now so he goes home and
he's like all right I don't know if
there's gonna be a business I don't
think so but he's like I just need to
start programming in just to get my you
know get get the rust off and so he
builds a Facebook app that was stupid it
was like a superlatives app like which
of your friends is most likely to end up
in jail or whatever boom goes viral you
know he ends up with tens of millions of
users and that changed the trajectory of
his life where Silicon Valley starts
calling him and you know Duvall flies
him out to San Francisco and wants to
invest in a suit like that so he took a
bet on the sort of day the platform
launched if I'm a board developer today
or I'm somebody who's got you know the
ability to code and you know a weekend I
would be building something on top of
snap kit the thing I would build is
actually so I think what's hard is when
you want to build something that gets
the user to leave snapchat and come to
your app so you kind of have to build
something that can actually do the whole
experience should just be on snapchat
and it should not compete with what
snapchat does so here's the idea okay
yes I call it cameo kick so basically I
think you could build the app cameo on
top of snapchat so you were basically
the cameo Kate would just say cool I
want to buy a snapchat from one of these
celebrities and I'll pay you right here
through snapchat and then I want to send
it either to myself or to my friend on
my snapchat list so basically imagine I
it's your birthday coming up right
when's your birthday it's in a few days
yeah you actually bought me a cameo you
had Gilbert Godfried call me a [__]
right so I did that last year but but
this year I could do it through
a little new invention of mine so
basically I would go in snapchat I would
open it up I would see a list of
influencers that are that have snapchat
which is like every celebrity in the
world I would request a video and I pay
right there and then you would receive a
snapchat from either from me or from
them in your inbox and the whole cameo
experience could be built on top of
snapchat without having to have separate
websites separate apps all that stuff
and you compete with cameo very quickly
so I think that's a very simple idea
that could monetize on top of snap get
[Music]